Les experts de kpmg roulaient dans l'argent
qu'ils avaient trouvé de l'or pour cacher
la fortune de certains de leurs Canadiens les plus riches
derrière les forteresses de l'île de Man
dans le plus grand secret la
Sonata da da
Medusa Viscusi Kamala's Angela rivet le
détective mais aujourd'hui les clients révèlent comment
le Sham  fonctionne
la réalité de Salah supposerait que
Lakeisha, l'élection de l'absolution de contrôle de Kinsella
pour la dernière fois du Likud grâce à
KPMG, ces multimillionnaires n'ont jamais eu
à faire face à des poursuites judiciaires, un équilibre que
Davidoff a commencé à avoir s'il s'agit d'une
force de surface de Michaels autour de la
boucle vitae à la place l'Agence du revenu du Canada
leur a offert un  permis d'amnistie dans l'
amnistie gal l'agence a dit qui sont
ces clients mystérieux notre
enquête nous mène à certains des
Canadiens les plus riches protégés par l'un des
cabinets comptables les plus influents
du pays
[Musique]
Madrid l'une des grandes
capitales européennes événements riches et culturels  la
destination touristique idéale pour attirer
des experts fiscaux du monde entier à la conférence de l'
International Fiscal Association
l'un des principaux sponsors de
la conférence est le géant comptable KPMG
au programme cinq jours de réunions
conférences et discussions sur les
questions de fiscalité internationale l'utilisation des
paradis fiscaux par  les riches et les
multinationales sont devenues très
controversées et les experts savent que le vent
tourne alors que les Panama Papers et maintenant
les affaires des Bahamas nous ont montré qu'il y a un
ressentiment croissant contre la
structure fiscale mondiale, en particulier dans le contexte
des impôts
et vous avez juré de vous opposer aux autorités fiscales
riches les plus grands
cabinets comptables sont prêts à se battre l'
un des meilleurs associés de KPMG a été très
clair dans cette vidéo d'entreprise de 2015 si nous
laissons simplement les régulateurs si nous laissons les autres
parties prenantes découvrir
à quoi ressemblera le paysage fiscal je ne suis pas
si sûr que  franchement, ce sera bien
pour nos clients pour nous, mais de
manière réaliste pour la société, je pense que nous pouvons
aider à construire un système fiscal du futur
et j'ai hâte de jouer un rôle important
dans cette reconnaissance nationale à Kitab, mon
animal de compagnie foxy Dollansky Yacouba CUDA Velma
chanson kappa - Je suppose que cela montre une
spécialiste dyslectique de la fiscalité internationale
Marwa risky dit que les grands cabinets comptables
sont au cœur des problèmes d'
évasion fiscale et d'évasion fiscale chimiorécepteur
SCL visqueux encyclique tirer sur le
testeur il y a environ 20 ans, les grands
cabinets comptables étaient en concurrence  pour
créer des stratégies fiscales qui étaient
de plus en plus rentables mais aussi de plus
en plus risquées, je pense qu'il y avait une
perception qu'ils ne se faisaient jamais prendre. L'
avocat fiscaliste Michael Hamersley travaillait
pour KPMG aux États-Unis.  à l'époque, l'
environnement était constitué de transactions qui
étaient vendues qui étaient très risquées et
nous ne représentons pas les faits réels de
la transaction avec une décision commerciale
et si elle était conforme ou non à la
loi que le préjudice d'enfreindre la
loi était essentiellement  une tape sur le poignet
et vous pourriez devenir riche en le faisant
au Canada - les experts fiscaux de KPMG ont proposé
un stratagème offshore très lucratif
selon des documents internes, les
clients ciblés devraient avoir plus de 5 millions de
dollars à investir à l'étranger la chienne était
alléchante pas d'impôt sur le revenu  à payer sur
les gains en capital et la confidentialité garantie pour
chaque vente
KPMG gagnerait au moins 100 000 $
à l'interne l'entreprise a claironné des
ventes réussies louant dit bolado un
partenaire montréalais un homme d'affaires canadien a accepté de
révéler anonymement le contenu de ses
rencontres confidentielles avec un
partenaire de KPMG sondage G safer Peggy  lamorne
Apple OCC possible Népal / ug - à Maui
Pandu viene de votre image parlant de
tonalité de domicile Ansel Valley ne Apache
fiscale mal une petite démo l'île de Man
est située dans la mer d'Irlande le
taux d'imposition des sociétés est de zéro pour cent KPMG
en tant que bureau  dans la capitale Douglas KPMG
crée une société offshore pour son
client l'entreprise recrute également des résidents de l'île de
Man ce sera des
actionnaires nominés le client canadien cède sa
fortune à la société offshore qui
s'installe devient la sélection de la ville un
leader maintenant ceccacci cage joliment
aimé em  si accrocheur qu'ils ne l'apaisent pas
venir elle mouille a voyagé d'une manière folle faite
confirmez que vous avez une déclaration que le client ne
déclare rien à l'Agence du revenu du Canada
puisque techniquement il n'est plus
le propriétaire au fil du temps sa fortune grandit
lorsqu'il veut ramener des fonds
au Canada  tout ce qu'il a à faire est de demander à l'
entreprise de lui faire un cadeau un cadeau hors taxe
mais selon le professeur de droit Andre
laho c'est de la fumée et des miroirs los que
le configurable Oh homie de la Rosa
l'élasticité della dama de marrón de la
Rosa coûte une élite  a cat lair
por que pasol kailasam de valor revenue
mr twemlow sin episode Oh dog LoCascio une
agence immobilière donc par défaut Cal personnes et
esprit de Barras amis de la rocca pmj
pauvre pécheur clé de document infinitif
vitani - so Larson test logic know
sanneh Oh malédictions Chadwick Catholic
plaidoyer des officiels tablette Ladera ou
opération sociale même s'il n'est pas
actionnaire le multimillionnaire garde le
contrôle de sa fortune en siégeant au
conseil d'administration csleater pada
transaction Corrigan est Nava transaction
Java ME mo Java et qu'est-ce qui met son veto pour
créer une encore plus opaque  écran
KPMG recommandait à ses clients de demander à un
ami de confiance de siéger au conseil d'administration pour
eux Le plan de kpmg comprenait également un
accord secret qui donnerait au
client de son ami un
pouvoir extraordinaire à tout moment, il pourrait liquider
l'entreprise et ramener l'argent au
Canada
Oh  bourgeon cort dire à Zula contrôler
l'absolution aha
choc touristique Bhupati 18 façade todo
militant Oscars société solaire de contrôle des lipides
peut livrer sûrement Tsubasa
je sélectionne ceux-ci sont acaba
séjour unidirectionnel capitaine ouvrier aucune
robe trouvée absurdité ne fais pas le soleil
l'élégance peut correspondre à 0,8 ammoniac  clé
expose les non-fans Calatrava merde vous voyez
la grammaire des propriétaires et comme moi il a fait
une bonne action II n'a même pas envoyé d'e-mail à KPMG
conteste catégoriquement qu'il s'agit d'une
déclaration fiable dit que les clients
ont été explicitement informés qu'ils
abandonnent le contrôle des actifs  à ce jour,
ni les clients de KPMG ni l'entreprise
elle-même n'ont été accusées d'
évasion fiscale criminelle onhc no pardon town donc SCO
nutella's Japan Claire modéré
tonifie également le consommateur je sais voir la détente Tosca
suppose qu'ela Castillo qui a dit que certaines
Cassie collectionnent des
namazi bien secrets Ola méritent un  China
cafe un kanji à l'
unité de dilution vaginale sous notification la
confidentialité à Fallujah peut repousser
dosa Akiko Kamala's all still of new
Vitesse détecte un monsieur en effet
les autorités fiscales canadiennes n'ont rien détecté
jusqu'en 2012 à Victoria la famille Cooper
vivait dans des maisons de luxe mais ils ont déclaré
tel  de petits revenus qu'ils ont payé très
peu ou pas d'impôts du tout, ils
réclament même des crédits d'impôt
mais ils se sont assis sur un énorme 26 millions de
dollars les agences du revenu les giflent avec
une pénalité de six millions de dollars
l'affaire est devant la Cour canadienne de l'impôt
je pense alors tu dois  parlez à
KPMG tout était caché derrière une
structure de société offshore sur l'île
de Man c'est là que nous avons poursuivi notre
enquête avec le professeur Lihue nous
avons été accueillis par un mur de silence quelque chose
comme ça un local commun après un
jugement sur Saravanan DeCoteau reprendre le partage des
revenus en direct la cerveza  de nies
agua a déclaré la liste vanille dakea daca
PMG a dr.  Nadeau Lisa Quichotte vivre
le bonheur ici à Vancouver les
enquêteurs de l'Agence du revenu ont obtenu une
ordonnance du tribunal en 2013
KPMG a été chargé de remettre les
noms de ses clients mais il a refusé et
a fait appel de la décision et puis rien pendant
plus de deux ans
l'affaire était grande Kizuna va coûter  nous
Cap'n astana sake pas de mégapole fonctionnelle
KPMG verse quoi que ce soit derrière
des portes closes
KPMG concluait un accord avec l'Agence du revenu
afin que ses clients riches ne soient
pas traduits en justice Les clients riches de KPMG
pouvaient toujours profiter de la vie et ne pas
trop s'inquiéter même si le revenu du Canada
L'agence avait jeté son dévolu sur eux,
le puissant cabinet comptable avait
réalisé un exploit remarquable en
négociant pour eux un accord secret que
nous avons obtenu d'une source anonyme,
les clients n'avaient qu'à payer les arriérés d'impôts
à un taux d'intérêt réduit, sans pénalité
ni poursuite
échangez l'Agence du revenu a exigé que son
offre reste strictement confidentielle
à moins que la famille ne soit au courant d'un
scan d'aérosol crypté sur l'impact du moto SC
sur l'effet que les massages sont pires
se produisent lelou un caucus septique à Ottawa
nos révélations sont venues comme une bombe
le système d'exploitation canadien est une aventure Merci
Pierre Metro mentionne en el deporte a la
sample a dispel Kathy open season sur le
polygone de montebello quality fiscal qui
peut vraiment vous identifier stop all Depot is
no testing ichika brahma le nouveau
premier ministre libéral était prêt à reconsidérer
l'accord conclu sous le
gouvernement conservateur quoi  les décisions
prises sous un gouvernement précédent si
leurs erreurs les examineront à coup
sûr un mois plus tard, les libéraux ont augmenté
le budget de l'agence et annoncé de nouvelles
mesures.
sept
experts indépendants conseilleront le ministre
dont deux du Québec consultant fiscal
Alan Lottie en droit fiscal professeur Mary T
Allah Emma conscience après circoncision
fo me swift
Allah SAS KPMG kaydessa Syrie pour devenir
un chat Jasmine sont les libéraux ont permis
au comité des finances d'étudier le
offre d'amnistie aux clients de KPMG
enfin l'affaire allait être
mise au jour mais en fait c'est le
contraire qui s'est produit ce matin étude de mot des
efforts de l'Agence du revenu du Canada
pour lutter contre l'évitement et
la fraude fiscale
il y a eu le premier témoin l'
ancien chef mondial de l'herbe à poux de kpmg  qui
étaient les employés de l'ARC qui ont négocié
l'accord d'amnistie avec KPMG chez votre
client Je ne suis pas autorisé à parler d'aucun
aspect du règlement car
il est soumis au privilège du règlement qui
étaient vos principaux contacts avec l'ARC comme je l'ai
dit plus tôt c'est un aspect
cette conversation que je ne
peux malheureusement pas entrer dans les humains comme sur les
commandes du parti Pascal : fois préserver un
dilemme ici à Holloman pgb Lucca
meatiness le 9 juillet Picabo sauf
à travers protège la confidentialité
Gregg wieb dit que le stratagème de l'homme olive était
tout à fait légal à l'époque tel quel  dans le
cas de tous nos plans fiscaux, il était pleinement
conforme à toutes les lois fiscales applicables, nous avons
effectué une
vérification préalable interne et externe approfondie en plaçant des
investissements et des sociétés offshore et en
revenant ici au Canada en tant que cadeau
d'une société à une autre société pensez-vous que
ce genre de  le comportement est immoral,
nous avons déterminé en 2003 que c'était
quelque chose que nous n'étions plus
prêts à mettre en œuvre en tant qu'organisation,
c'était une époque très différente. Je veux dire que nous
avions l'habitude de fumer dans les restaurants en 2006.
les voitures jusqu'à il y a deux ans, les temps changent
et nous changeons avec lui envoyé des
jeux populaires comme un cordial transveineux
le revenu total reçu par KPMG pour
ce package particulier offrait les 16
implémentations, les frais moyens étaient
d'environ 100 000 $, de sorte que les frais totaux que
nous aurions reçus pour
la mise en œuvre de ce plan particulier étaient
un peu moins de 1,6 million de dollars. c'était
un frais fixe par  mise en œuvre, il
ne s'agissait pas de frais conditionnels,
mais son témoignage est contredit par un
document de marketing interne déposé au
tribunal.
KPMG jusqu'en 2008 au total
300 000 $ KPMG dit que ce ne sont que des
allégations de l'agence du revenu, les
informations fournies par Gregg weed au
comité de la Chambre des communes étaient correctes
pour les tours de mois les plus efficaces sur le
temps de Matsu palomar dans lesquels je peux sauter
do you don '  Ne parlez pas de Christine de la Fidèle
et scannez aussi - L'Italie ne
me fait pas peur, profitons seulement quelques semaines
après le témoignage de KPMG,
c'est au tour des ministres du revenu de
répondre et de poser des questions sur l'
amnistie secrète de votre puissant à Novato
dans les
pécheurs de la densité yazhini  seul le presento clé
spécifiquement jacques de classe de
Clairvaux délivre émission ESMA non gras
réveillé pénalité attribuée bavière tasaku
tonalité illest OG o intolérance et -
honnêteté Masuka comment vida nationalité
musica courbe de taille où est Vicki Layton
et mystère mamelon n MK e gdz dans ce
rapport est un  séquence spéciale détective
McCormack L amnistie administrative
shakaal une telle affaire de diffamation sur della
patria
deuxième annonce la majorité du laboratoire Papa ye dis une
minute le ministre a même refusé de
confirmer l'authenticité de la lettre
offrant l'amnistie aux clients de KPMG
activer l'alerte du château pour se laver plus tard
transit en mai même pour voir le
document des communautés permet Evelyn laissez-
moi supposer qu'un homme existe un fabricant de bombes nouvelle
taille de Solanki désirs clairs
ne faisons pas oh c'est nee avec vine site
clear sis cuticle nipper Palakkad le
résidu kannada adah cbc s-curve  avec une
sortie super confirmée coupes externes le
coût total soutien supplémentaire immédiat
malicieusement Presutti l a déclaré criminel
à palana pas d'oscillation SoLoMo notre
signal physiquement dynastie de quelques
étudiants elle peut trop énorme le genou
ne laissons pas le comité appelle alors une
série de  des experts indépendants, mais le
jour de l'audience, ils ne peuvent pas entrer dans la
salle, le comité se réunit à Camera
Raw mille une dernière poupée kalila consulter
dr.  Hayden McHale systole appelle la
réunion à deux ordres tout d'un coup le
président du comité libéral wainy
serf ordonne aux experts de ne pas parler
du scandale KPMG Daz je crois qu'un témoin
ou un membre se dirige dans une direction
qui pourrait avoir des implications sur le
tribunal  cas alors je leur demanderai d'
être coupé et et passer à la question suivante
pochamma abeja combi apt ASP Sofia
SEO direct compliqué van der kappa OMG
le de pas égal au coup l'
inepte préservé sa innocent de
répliques panzanella mr.  LaRue
bonjour dans votre chambre oh non pas vraiment
qui est le professeur diversité calles de
Laval
Giovanni celada a lil Dena por la que de
la Li da y ji Liberty Molotov ASEAN se
Swasey
de ribera de la cienega aucun doc n'apparaît une
torsion malignité commune pop un leader
kappa OMG le de ma robuste métabee
ennoblissement la stratégie moi topless
daca PNG en haut sur le podium pop je
préférerais que tu n'entres vraiment pas dans
le KP
l'affaire c'est celle qui est juste
devant les tribunaux si tu veux parler dedans
généralités sur l'évasion fiscale c'est
bien mais je ne veux pas emprunter un chemin
ce n'est pas un Castro mr.  président que nous venons
juste d'être invité à parler du service de
livraison d'opportunités énergétiques KPMG Kappa
Oh la Commission de la défense est toujours des
émissions de télévision comme une analyse des coûts
déceptions périodiques Casio vascularité SEMA médecin
au comité Hollander pourquoi le
président du comité a-t-il fait
un couple à l'envers  Quelques jours plus tôt, les avocats de KPMG
ont envoyé une lettre au comité invoquant
la règle du sous-Gudice, une règle qui dit qu'il ne
faut pas interférer dans le processus judiciaire,
mais Wayne Easter dit que la lettre n'a eu aucune
influence sur lui, les conseils que nous avons
examinés provenaient du juriste parlementaire
conseil et jusqu'où vous devriez ou
ne devriez pas aller si freaking la voce Lang
handicap por semana de Anita's expand
isatis AMA La Palma pooh-pooh silica
certains enfants étaient conv Kelly T singe
a déposé du silicium uniquement Trevino silica
sunset naturellement selon le professeur
Graham sur le  comité diffusé dire
conscience Bank a low près d'un paysan et
Apache voir Molina sur Pierce extrema me
pal police hola pues el puente Le cas d'Antonio
et un chercheur de commissaire sur le
balcon Tom SEO donc City Japan seul
effet individuel supprimé
faisons également du vélo emoji un petit
univers Dena  pignon conditionnel un
perceptible Je sais que la ruée vers les croissants maintenant
une autre réunion d'affaires a été ajournée
et ce qui s'est passé avec le
comité consultatif indépendant annoncé par le
ministre les noms des deux Québécois
Alan Lottie et Mariana étaient
introuvables dans le rapport publié en
décembre dernier GM Comité sénatorial CalSTRS  man
kakoton a vanity fuji sahaba époque où
je vais satin reserve abajo function
man's candy paruparu cigale a bodybag
antique dans une lettre adressée au
ministre la professeure remet en
cause l'indépendance du
comité
elle écrit des hauts fonctionnaires de l'
agence du revenu du canada et du président
du comité a déterminé les sujets de l'ordre du jour
discutés et les questions soulevées
pièce exquise bancale le plafonnement
surtout pas une étiologie de Nez
dépôt sifflet est montré considérer
l'esturgeon atomique de nécessité 1 Samuel
Curtis virgule chilidog repentir cubique
eadamson perte de demi-vérité lavage KPMG
de hong  le stockage kong kappa tech15 peut
clignoter
pendant des années les experts fiscaux de kpmg ont vendu leur
stratagème à des clients fortunés les aidant à
cacher leur fortune à l'
Agence du revenu du Canada
combien de multimillionnaires ont acheté le
stratagème et qui sont-ils le
cabinet comptable prétend avoir vendu un stratagème 16 fois
les noms de  les clients n'ont jamais été
révélés publiquement à l'exception d'
une famille Victoria Coopers pour qui KPMG a
créé une société globale sur l'île de
Man - Candice boîte d'argent sawol sukira
Toshiba voir le 1283 dit la vanité
bleu océans nous connaissons Ben Affleck
[Musique]
donc votre  péninsule légale à l'île de
Man
nous avons trouvé des indices dans le registre des sociétés
nous permettant d'identifier plusieurs
canadiens impliqués nous recherchons des sociétés
dont les statuts étaient
identiques à ceux de la
société de la famille Cooper certains articles inhabituels
ont attiré notre attention comme celui-ci
interdisant les administrateurs  pour se rencontrer au
Canada nous avons trouvé plus de 20 entreprises de
cette façon l'une d'elles a vu Jackie Company
Limited créée en 2000 un canadien siège
au conseil d'administration Frederick
William a été administrateur chez gold video
tall limited donc Jackie est aussi le nom
d'une holding canadienne  qui
appartient aux fondateurs de la famille Xiang Yan du
géant de la communication vidéo parler pourquoi
les ombres du schéma KPMG
ne nous kpop que pour nous embêter à Sioux City et
dans dénote l'unité technique un article sur Mindanao
bhakti-rasa pour pourquoi sensible Scott nous
trouvons d'autres indices révélateurs  sir Jackie a
été enregistré à l'île de Man
Le 3 février 2000 le même jour à
la Barbade et dans d'autres paradis fiscaux,
donc Jackie holding et donc Jackie
investissements ont été créés pour d'autres
sociétés liées aux Shang Yuans
car c'est plus tard à Montréal une
conférence de presse a envoyé des ondes de choc à travers le Québec
paysage politique c'est un grand jour
pour le Canada c'est un grand jour pour le Québec
et c'est très excitant pour nos
entreprises la famille Xiang a annoncé la
fusion de gold video Tom avec Rogers
Communications appartenant au
milliardaire ontarien Ted Rogers une transaction
évaluée à 5,6 milliards de dollars  depuis Suzy
Olivet Rogers,
vous savez qu'en tant qu'action policière, je
le ramène à un avantage tout aussi clair et grand
pour le propre portefeuille de la Chine
puisque la transaction impliquait l'échange
d'actions Shan young pouvait différer le paiement
de l'impôt sur les gains en capital en repoussant un
impôt  facture qui aurait pu atteindre plus de
700 millions de dollars West a rejeté l'
homme olive dans le cadre de la planification fiscale de Chanel
Oprah dit hé l'équipe de Kevin Suki est une place
dans les sutures pitocin FA lepetit skv écoute
caca charité poursuivre Rue bio
italien mais les chaînes ont fait face à un
défi inattendu de  le
gouvernement du Québec McAfee Anton de première fois
que Rogers aller un Qatari Lillet sont
extraordinaire entrepreneur Shannon
Shetty
une théorie se concentre sur les vitamines ET dans la
peau de porc et le druide madanpal un abandonné
comme dépôts un Cecil Skell nain
irrégulier G Saddam un formulaire de don pour
Medicaid le  pharmacien aux amandes douces les
jours de garde accordé l'affaire le défaut d'un
actionnaire de vidéo Tom a usé de son
droit de veto pour bloquer la transaction l'affaire a
ensuite demandé à Piaf Calpol un propriétaire de chien de
téléphérique de faire une contre-offre d'abord
rejetée par les chaînes bétail colpal
aimé le Rogers  La police a accidentellement
jeté un filet pas un costume et un son mais l'
offre de voitures pour enfants était en espèces Zhang
Yuans aurait dû payer immédiatement
des impôts sur la cabine des hommes de gains en capital
Hoffa dans un pochoir n'est pas une
population dans le besoin Tony Hawk peut posséder l'objectif
de décomposition Becker  dit que l'académicien semble
handicapé face à l'opposition de la
distribution les chaînes se sont retirées le 27 avril
puis dans leur société de l'île de man
sans l'avoir utilisé ma chaîne de griffe de courrier électronique
confirme qu'aucun actif ou fonds n'a
été transféré à la société Iowa man
sept jours plus tard le Lucy  La
fondation Ananda Chanyeol a été enregistrée auprès
de la fondation de l'Agence du revenu du Canada et
a reçu une grande partie des revenus
générés par la vente de la ville vidéo à la
stratégie d'attaque chimique qui n'a pas
nui à l'image des chaînes car ils sont devenus des
philanthropes de premier plan parmi les
autres sociétés de l'île de Man.  trouver
des investissements gask créés en 2001, nos recherches
suggèrent qu'il est lié au neveu de Ted Rogers,
David Robinson, il a été pendant de nombreuses
années vice-président de Rogers
Communications, il est maintenant vice-
président principal de la Rogers Bank Robinson
a refusé de répondre à nos courriels et
messages téléphoniques  snow a été créé en 2004
pour que les Québécois y soient liés Oh Malik
voir un entrepreneur immobilier qui
passe ses hivers en Floride d'après
son notaire il s'est installé avec une
agence du revenu du Canada et de l'avenue Québec l'
autre est andré a dessiné Homme
ancien entrepreneur de comptoir de cuisine dans le
lettre Vaughn nous a dit qu'il était simplement un
candidat pour la causeuse Je n'ai jamais transféré
d'actifs mais n'était qu'une figure de proue pour
aider il dit que le baryum de l'entreprise est
lié à l'entreprise de confiserie Winnipeg
la famille d'oiseaux propriétaire de l'usine de club nutty
établie plus de cent
ans  il y a son président Jim Burt admet que
KPMG l'a approché, il dit qu'il
n'a pas acheté le programme un de ses fils
se présente en tant qu'administrateur de la société offshore
certains documents suggèrent que s KH est
lié au milliardaire ontarien Vig
n'est pas un bénéficiaire de  l'Ordre du
Canada impliqué dans l'immobilier commercial
et l'industrie du plastique au nord de
Toronto et investit en attendant la
pensée en 2012 sk h a été transféré à
st.  Kitts et Nevis un paradis fiscal des Caraïbes
la nouvelle adresse de sjh s'avère
être la même qu'un complexe de luxe appartenant
à la victime, il a également refusé de répondre à nos
questions un citadin est venu comme un
désordre national dans un petit
laboratoire de célécoxib et a préféré  tout le
public entier la faute des phénomènes provient d'
une fuite l'un des administrateurs de Cal far 43
est le Michigan sait que l'actuel PDG de
resolute Quebec slaw exhorte l'
entreprise de l'industrie forestière mon courriel il écrit que
son rôle au sein de cette société était une
affaire privée
qui a précédé son  association avec
résolu, il dit qu'il ne peut divulguer aucune
information confidentielle concernant
les autres et que lui et sa famille n'ont
reçu aucun avantage personnel si le
pétrole du Michigan n'est que le front que le riche
Canadien se cache derrière Cal Fire 43 le
mystère reste l'
automne dernier des experts fiscaux du monde entier  le
monde a goûté à la vie nocturne légendaire de Madrid
la conférence annuelle de l'
Association fiscale internationale
dont KPMG est l'un des principaux sponsors
a organisé des événements somptueux dans certains des
points de repère du somptueux
musée du Prado a été loué pour une soirée culturelle
parmi les participants à cette  événement
Le juge Denny Ben C de la Cour d'
appel fédérale sa cour entend les appels de
la Cour de l'impôt
un porte-parole a d'abord nié que le juge ait
jamais assisté à des événements d'accueil,
y compris celui au Prado parce que
sa femme ne se sentait pas bien, mais
les voici après avoir révélé que nous avions  a tourné
cette vidéo, son porte-parole a admis avoir
assisté aux événements et a déclaré que la
confusion initiale était due à
une mauvaise communication deux jours plus tard, il y
avait une soirée privée sur invitation uniquement
sur l'une des terrasses les plus exclusives de
la capitale espagnole le toit l'événement
a été entièrement payé par  la branche canadienne
du cabinet d'avocats Denton's Marwa risky
a assisté à la conférence mais pas la
mafia du préfixe de cocktail privé et cette
huître a la consultation k12 et
Bischoff disent que cela fonctionne sur une cuillère d'erreur
le kdeeny cloggin est de nouveau allumé
Scott D devient ce qu'il vient de dire
cuisine  et c'est une Nancy qui l'a tiré vers le
gars du marketing Thomas sur nous de l'
ancienne Fraser Milner de Chandni Denton était le
cabinet qui a fourni des conseils juridiques en 1999
à KPMG validant le stratagème de l'île de Man
parmi les participants à la
fête de Denton était un autre
juge canadien Randall taureau coq de  la Cour de l'impôt,
il est le juge de gestion dans l'affaire
impliquant le régime de l'île de Man de KPMG dans
la famille Cooper.
de quoi yo yo yo yo tourner correos
SEO danseur cartel Papa Bobby maman
Missy Paula soutien neffeteria vous savez le
beurre de spaghetti si le
ratio de processus de plasma époxy risquera de supposer que
nos neveux neveu principal d'annapolis et
c'est ainsi qu'il est énoncé dans le
code de conduite des conseils judiciaires canadiens
le professeur Leo croit que le juge en chef
de la Cour canadienne de l'impôt
devrait appeler ses juges à l'ordre le directeur de la défense
Joseph Rossiter est-ce que j'ai rencontré injecter
des problèmes sérieux puis un pop qui a craché à
la queue Teleca Driscoll Lamar
délicieux je vois que j'ai épluché mais
le juge en chef  n'est pas d'accord, vous
connaissez un e-mail, il dit que le juge Volkov
ne s'est pas mis en situation de
conflit d'intérêts en
assistant brièvement à une réception ouverte à
tous les participants de la conférence lors d'
une autre conférence sur la fiscalité à Calgary
quelques mois plus tard loin de
condamnant la pratique, le juge en chef l'
a encouragé en se vantant qu'il
continuerait lui-même à assister à
des événements d'hospitalité
mes chroniques de Camaro la table si
étiquetée une voiture avec une posture de pénalité
énorme scalaire du Japon contient les mascottes
château de conneries indécis aux
États-Unis les autorités ont traduit KPMG en
justice pour  vendre des abris fiscaux abusifs
au cours de la même période que le
stratagème de l'île de Man au Canada, nous
ne pouvons tout simplement pas tolérer un abus flagrant de la loi
et des normes professionnelles par des
fiscalistes, en particulier ceux
associés à des sociétés dites de premier ordre
comme l'avocat fiscaliste KPMG Michael
Hammersley a travaillé pour KPMG aux États-Unis.
en 2003, il est devenu un lanceur d'alerte
contre son ancien employeur.
J'ai finalement refusé d'approuver ce que
je croyais être une conduite illégale des
partenaires fiscaux de KPMG impliqués dans l'audit
peu de temps après que les professionnels ont perdu
leur boussole de responsabilités morales et professionnelles
et ils
ont pensé et je pense que le  les conséquences
ont été beaucoup plus graves qu'ils ne l'
avaient prévu aux états-unis.  huit
cadres supérieurs de KPMG ont été inculpés trois d'entre
eux sont allés en prison un cabinet d'experts-comptables a été
condamné à une amende de 456 millions de dollars league rockin
a hotel no decapitation hacia el emilio
de dólar de PhD la cuillère soufie un pays
AFET a co trailer
imagine a co crayon Ellis L sang Co
possible  Kiva par le leila decision la
tradición de Liberty yo pal ha
Damodar don't defend a prisoner session
Sissoko body the Nisswa Yosh
s'échappant ainsi au Canada KPMG et leurs
comptables ne font jamais face à la justice cabinet qui se voit
toujours attribuer des millions de dollars en
contrats chaque année par le gouvernement fédéral
Alice hey Encantada Ricardo ho chi
gentils gars comme Amazon les
divas disco sur Scott un ducat J'annulerai le
contrat
KPMG soutient que son plan a été très
soigneusement développé et examiné et
qu'il était conforme aux lois certains disent que
l'entreprise devrait faire l'objet d'une
enquête policière  stratagème et pour ses
relations avec l'Agence du revenu du Canada,
dernier épisode, des solutions adéquates, vous savez,
Kate et moi avons découvert da na GFC pour un
baiser composé entre un compte d'actifs à
utiliser de KPMG lassie, vous verrez que la
ghréline fait partie de notre pas aussi
privilégié donc  réussi l'identité
des véritables propriétaires de certaines des
sociétés de l'île de man reste encore un mystère
la plupart des structures offshore ont maintenant
été liquidées en raison de l'amnistie
négociée par KPMG certains de ces
multimillionnaires n'auront pas à faire face à la
justice pour l'instant ils restent  intouchable
[Musique]